IAN LAKE: When you have to
do something really important
right now, unlocking your
phone, opening an app,
and navigating to the right
place is a lot of work.
On API 24 and higher
devices, though, there's
an alternative-- a
Quick Settings tile.
Now, your app can provide its
own tiles for quick access
to critical functionality.
Once users have manually
added your tile,
they'll be able to view
your tile by swiping down
the notification tray, either
as just an icon if you're
in the first few spots, or
with up to two lines of text
and the icon in the full
Quick Settings panel.
Even better, the full
Quick Settings panel
is available even if
the device is locked.
Users can then tap on
your Quick Settings tile
to trigger a callback, where
you can kick off some background
work, show a dialog,
or start an activity.
Now, that's pretty useful
for those really frequent
or urgent tasks.
And that's really what Quick
Settings tiles are all about.
They're not just for
launching your app.
You have a home
screen icon for that.
So think about the
critical operations that
can be very easily
understood with a simple icon
and a quick tap or
through a simple dialog
to provide a bit more context.
Now, your Quick
Settings tile is going
to be controlled and managed
through a tile service.
Note that your app
name will be displayed
right next to the name of
the Quick Settings tile.
So give a descriptive
name and icon that
hints at what it actually does.
Space is pretty limited
here, so keep it
under 18 characters
for the label.
The icon here should
be solid white
on a transparent background.
Think of it as just
the alpha channel.
Remember, you can
use a vector drawable
as you'll only be enabled on
API 24 and higher devices.
The lifecycle of a
Quick Settings tile
is a bit different from
many services, though.
And there's three main parts.
First, when your tile is added
to the Quick Settings panel,
the system will bind to your
service and call onTileAdded().
After that, each time
your tile is visible,
the system will yet again bind
to your tile service and call
onStartListening().
This is the point where you're
expected to keep the tile up
to date all the way until
you receive a callback
onStopListening(), which is when
the tile's no longer visible.
These make a natural pairing
if you need to set up
any listeners for changes.
Finally, when-- I mean, if
the user were to ever remove
your tile, you'd again have
the system bind to your service
and call onTileRemoved().
Keep in mind that the lifecycle
is controlled by the system
here.
So don't assume that
your service will
persist between these states.
There's another mode
called active mode.
Read the blog post
linked in the description
for how that differs from the
passive mode described here.
OK, let's say we've received a
callback to onStartListening()
and we want to update our tile.
You'll call getQsTile to get
the tile instance associated
with the tile service.
This is what allows you
to update the icon, label,
and content description.
It also allows you to set
the state of the tile.
There are three
states for a tile.
Active corresponds with
the on or enabled state.
Inactive is the off
or disabled state.
And the system automatically
tints your icon
to indicate the inactive state.
Really useful if you have
a tile that naturally fits
with an on-off toggle model.
And finally, the
unavailable state--
this would be appropriate if
your tile needs internet access
and you're offline,
for instance.
Users can't click on your
tile when it's unavailable,
unlike the other two states.
Just remember, once you've
updated everything you need,
you need to call updateTile.
This is what actually triggers
the system to update your tile.
One other pretty core part
to a Quick Settings tile,
though-- handling clicks.
You'll get a callback to your
tile service's onClick method
whenever the user
taps your tile.
From here, you
have a few options.
The most common case is you
do want to do some background
work-- toggling some
internal state in your app
and updating your tile
with the new state.
You can also display a dialog
using the showDialog method.
This is useful if
the tile switches
between more than
two states or you
feel the user needs
some additional context,
such as what remote
device is being changed
or that you need to download
or upload some information.
There's also a startActivity
and Collapse method
for starting an activity
directly from the tile service.
Don't forget,
though-- users will
be able to access your tile
even if the device is securely
locked.
If you have something sensitive,
consider checking isSecure()
and modifying your behavior
to only show non-sensitive
information.
If the Quick Settings panel
is above the lock screen,
isLocked() will return true.
In this state, you won't be
able to use showDialog().
And you'll have to make
sure any activity you
start uses FLAG_SHOW_WHEN_LOCKED
to show above the lock screen.
There is a convenience
method, unlockAndRun(),
that will prompt the user
to unlock their device
if your click handling
requires an unlocked device
So Quick Settings
tiles are a great way
to give quick access to critical
functionality in your app.
Make sure they're intuitive
and save the user time
throughout the entire
lifetime of the app.
And you'll find them a great
way to build better apps.